feel comfortable you ready to go read
even Louis house man in the house I'm
excited man
you uh you hold a special place in my
heart because we started this podcast
journey basically at almost exactly the
same time you started a couple months
before me or maybe yeah like I think I
had like a two-month lead yeah how's the
big expert at that point I was like no I
do rich what'd I do
but I remember vividly you would just
move to LA and we had been introduced
and and and so I made my way over to
West Hollywood your pad and you were in
like some temporary apartment situation
and you broke out like the crappiest
little mics looked like and I'm like I
always do this and and we had a great
conversation and then we talked about
podcasting like what you what your
vision for what you were doing was at
that time and it was cool man we
connected down and then we sort of been
on each other's shows a couple times and
we've been on this you know journey
separately but kind of together like I'm
always checking in on you what's he
doing how is he growing Wow and you've
just exploded so I'm proud of you it's
really cool to see oh yeah well I always
look at your stuff because you have the
best newsletters you have like to clean
us design and I'm always like gosh he's
got such good design so I was appreciate
the way you deliver your message I
appreciate that man I put a lot of time
and do it probably too much you know but
like I like the detail CD right yes a
little bit man to my to my detriment at
times I think you know your and your URL
you would always say to me man you gotta
move forward like just keep going keep
you know good you let go a little bit
let people in you gotta systematize and
I like clutch on like trying to control
every little detail and I've gotten I've
grown a lot in that regard like we've
gotten a lot better I have a team now
and I have support and it's been amazing
but I still have that like impulse you
know that I'm trying to overcome a
little bit I hear you man it's hard for
me I wanted because I'm when I started
years ago in the online marketing space
I did everything myself from the
newsletter to the social media to the
customer support to the sales and
marketing webinars and I wanted to learn
at all but I think as I've let go more
and more it's like my business has grown
uh-huh so even though it's yeah
people make mistakes and I get
frustrated sometimes but it's like you
know what I want to be able to grow as
fast and I gotta be okay with some of
those mistakes because other people are
to make mistakes yeah well yeah that's
ultimately how you got you gotta let go
to grow yeah right and so now you gotta
like all these people that come over to
your apartment every day yes feel like
it's like in cringing like encroaching
on your access personal private space
like yeah are you able like create a
boundary around that because they're
literally like walking around your
bedroom not my bed kind of but I mean
it's close right there yeah I mean how
many people like you like five or six
people over there yeah ten total but
some have more you know they see in a
real office I think they're in other
cities so it's okay okay there's like
five or six here locally it just depends
on the record days then we have more
people in there but if they're not
recording a podcast and MySpace I think
like if I grew to three to six more
people I'd probably get another space
and like just do a little co-working
thing and figure it out right so the
dogs are barking hey man it's real life
real life we're living authentically
here we're in you know how a bass it's
Malibu you know so I'm interested before
we get in we're gonna unpack the book
and and you know your journey with
masculinity and all of that and you did
a great job with this book and Roger
thank you some exciting you're right at
the first page thanks for dropping right
here but before we do that like let's
just camp out a little bit on the
podcasting thing like I'm just
interested in what this journey has
meant to you
like where you see it going you know I
think I don't think either of us could
have foreseen at that time when we first
met that that you know each of our shows
would have the reach that they have and
and you know I certainly have thoughts
and opinions about like what it's meant
to me how it's changed my life and how I
approach it how I think about it you
know what is my responsibility to the
audience and you finding the right
guests and all of that like how do you
think about all that yeah I mean it's a
lot of impact but for me it's I mean
it's almost been five years for you
because I think you started in October
and end in November I think a of ever
cuz it's five years for me at end of
January right so yeah we're coming up on
the I can't believe I've it's crazy it
has changed my life has changed
everything about my business my life my
relationships and
it's been an amazing platform because
I've always wanted to share my message
but I know the best way to deliver it so
this has allowed me to have impact on
people and we do have you do it retreats
I do events and just to see you know
what's a thousand people come together
who found the podcast and found meaning
in some insights they heard on the
podcast and to say I'm gonna fly around
the world to come to this experience to
meet other people who listen as well see
speakers it's so amazing I just don't
know anywhere else I could could have
done that and deliver it in such an
intimate way where people are listening
for an hour you know have headphones on
or in their car their commute their
workouts when they're going to bed when
they're waking up some of the most
intimate times for people they're
listening and when you say you know I
really think about my audience and
curate the guests carefully because I'm
sure like you I have a lot of friends
who I'm like close with whom who I found
means like hey man what do you have me
on yeah and even not that close of
friends but just like well-known
business people are successful
entrepreneurs or whatever it may be
there's a guy right now who's messaged
me a lot who's got a book coming out
who's just messaging me like I'm not
gonna take no for an answer and I'm like
listen I say no to my family members to
my friends who I like love and it's not
about you it's about the community and
it's not about me and our relationship
it's about the community and there have
been times in the past where I had
people on cuz I felt pressured to and it
wasn't effective
it didn't get results from my community
and they questioned and they're like
why'd you do this so I've learned to
really make sure that I'm aware of who
I'm having on the topic the conversation
the flow of it to serve my audience in
the base look the biggest way because if
not I feel like it's doing a disservice
to the audience yeah I completely agree
with that and I'm I was just talking to
David about this the other day like I'm
in the same situation and I'm a people
pleaser by nature and I have people who
you know I have somebody who's messaging
me a lot right now and I feel like and
I'm like a conflict avoidant person so I
just dozed or
it's like I'm like please don't ask me
to be you know it puts me in an awkward
situation because like you it's like I'm
thinking about the audience what is the
best you know who are the best people
that I can bring on and you know I don't
do you do more episodes per week than I
do so I'm looking at okay so that that
leaves me 52 people a year you don't
want a week yeah I do sometimes I do a
second one but those are usually like q
and A's that I've done or things like
that I need 50 so the highest qualifying
and and and it's not it's not like the
most famous person or the most
accomplished it's like who's the right
fit mm who can I gel like who excites me
it's just as much about like who like
I've learned to trust my intuition and
I've made that mistake of everybody says
you need this person on and I'm like oh
you're not excited then I do it and then
because I'm not as into it as maybe
somebody else is then it ends up being
lackluster and it doesn't deliver it
doesn't laugh that's the challenge -
I've got my publisher is actually trying
to send me other authors that they
publish as well they're like well you
have this person on and this person on
and it's kind of like they expect me to
do it and I'm like listen my audience
you know if I'm not interested if I'm
not excited if it doesn't make me
curious then my audience is gonna be
excited either how they'll know they'll
see through it right there and then they
kind of make me feel bad and pressure me
more I'm like guys come on well it's a
it's a problem of success because in
there now like I remember in the
beginning it's like I'm scouring the
earth trying to get somebody to come on
who will say yes and now it's an
embarrassment of riches because you get
to cheat you get to choose and that
comes with it and that's amazing and I
get emails from publicists like pitching
book and all that kind of stuff so you
have access now that I didn't have or if
I tweet somebody like I can get a
response and it didn't used to be that
way but that carries with it the
responsibility to make sure that you're
serving the audience and what's in their
best interest and how do you curate you
know these guests to create an
experience that you know takes you from
one guest to the next and creates kind
of a thematic through line with you're
trying to accomplish do you feel like
you've lost any friends because you said
no two people are like people stopped
talking to you because you want to have
them on
I mean I don't know if it's gotten that
bad but you know it definitely it's just
awkward you know it was just awkward I
was at a con I spoke at a conference a
couple days ago and a lot of people
there it wasn't you know it was like a
thousand people and it was amazing and I
there's nothing more gratifying than
spending a couple hours afterwards like
talking to everybody who comes up and
like I want to give everybody the most
attention I can because they're telling
me you know their their personal stories
you know and that's a beautiful thing
that you want to honor and cherish
but there's the occasional person who
then you know gives you their card I'd
love to keep guest on the shows like or
whatever you have yeah that's that's
nice you know like if I had a book I
would do the same thing probably but
it's not a public access service you
know what I mean you know and it's easy
for me to like not be as mindful about
that boundary as I should be and I get
myself into trouble and I'm trying to
learn to be better because it is about
the audience right it is man otherwise
you'll lose the audience yeah Alton yeah
ultimately you know it works across
purposes when they're trying to do yeah
but you've grown this thing into like a
massive enterprise it's been Parliament
I had no idea like you that it would
take off this way and you know my last
two books are because the podcasts the
information I gained from the interviews
I did I turned into books you know
events courses programs speaking you
know all these getting on Ellen you know
all these things have happened because
the podcast they wouldn't have happened
without the podcast it was a it was a I
think we are at you know it's the one I
look at it like it's the one time in my
life where I feel like I was at the
right place at the right time I was it
wasn't cool when we started but it was
we were on the cusp of it becoming
something that nobody could have
foreseen because I think at that time
what people don't remember realize is
that podcasting was around from 2006
somewhere around then and it just kind
of was a stagnant thing you know it was
kind of growing but like no one was
really listen no one was catching on and
when I started I didn't think of it I
you know I didn't think of us being like
early adopters yes like it cool the
years yeah I mean it's it had been going
on but there was no indication that this
was on the cusp of becoming
a mainstream way to consume content you
know and what's special about it is what
you said earlier which is it is so
intimate you know it's the one form of
media that you can consume while you're
doing something else and people have
their earbuds on and you're like right
into their brain you know it's crazy and
I'm sure people say this to you all the
time like you know I go to bed with you
every night or there's me when I'm
cooking or on the treadmill or when I'm
commuting every day and and a
relationship develops you know and I
know this because I listen to other
podcasts and I feel like I'm friends
with these hosts that I've never met
there's something really like you know
powerful about that and I think it is
important as a host to remember that and
make sure that you're honoring that oh
yeah exactly
and it's easy to get you can get
starry-eyed and you know chase these
people who look great on paper but not
necessary not necessarily the best
people for the show and right and I
found and I'm interested in what you
think about this like it's super fun to
interview famous people I mean don't get
me wrong like that's like oh my god I
can't believe I'm sitting and talking
greed to do this but they're so seasoned
at doing interviews that it's really
difficult to don't open up yeah because
they're just like okay they're gonna do
their spiel and I feel like you almost
have to exhaust them or you got to
interrupt and throw them off their game
or do something like how can I make this
different or unique like how can I
approach this from a different angle and
that can be difficult so sometimes those
interviews end up being not as impactful
just because it feels like it's on the
surface you know I agree that's why I
have a process every time before I
interview someone I ask them a couple of
questions to get them ready to open up
and I ask them is there anything off
limits before we start I build rapport
we're connecting hanging out but then I
say okay it's ready the off limits that
you don't want to talk about and usually
most of the time they say no if they say
yes then I say well usually that thing
will actually be the most impactful
thing we talk about so I try to get them
to say yes do the thing they don't want
to talk about to talk about and then I
ask them okay do I have permission to
take this anywhere and everywhere to
make this the most impactful thing
you've ever done
then I just give it a beat and use it or
like oh okay this is about to be
something interesting mm-hmm and then I
say what would make this the most
powerful interview you've ever done what
we have to do say go be and then I think
just constantly kind of confirming and
grounding into that like this is gonna
be something different that's helped me
before trying to like pull something out
of them it's like they're already in
like an open state I feel like it's been
really efficient that's smart man I like
that that's interesting I asked the
person is there anything off limits that
I definitely do that as I want them to
feel comfortable and I want them to know
like hey man I'm not here to burn you
like I want and I say like look when
we're done with this if you you know a
day later you're like I wish I didn't
say this thing or I misspoke about this
can you change like I'm yeah man I'm
like you know I'm not here to
mischaracterize you that's not what this
is about like I just want to create that
sense of comfort but I like that follow
up line of questions interesting yeah it
helps have you have you been in that
situation where somebody's on your show
they're well-known but they're not
really like they don't they don't
totally know who you are what you do and
so they're like what am I doing here
like my publicist told me to be here but
like yeah head I had I got a couple of
those ones yeah I had meatloaf on him
that was that was interesting because he
was more just like constantly talking
about his like new record or whatever
his new CD I was like totally talking
about it and I was like okay let's talk
about other stuff and if you're if you
fascinate my audience I'm sure they'll
support you but if you just talk about
the thing the whole time like if I was
just here talking about get my book in
my book like every 10 seconds it'd be
like a boring interview mm-hmm so it's
almost like don't talk about the thing
you're trying to promote and give such
amazing value that people like I want to
support this person yeah like whatever
they have usually we have authors on
more selling books whatever owning books
and yeah and I think he's Oliver he's
just kind of like you know doing his
thing whatever but yeah still great you
know it's just it's it's uh I mean look
you know we both have these outlets and
so when people have books coming out
like you do like
they want to get it out there I'm like
I'm happy to oblige if I like the person
and I'm interested in the book is good
and I'm interested in what they have to
say but but I'm not here to be just your
service or whatever so yeah it has to be
it has to be a blend like that add value
give me 90 95 percent of all value and
then we'll talk about thing four five
percent and then I'll do a big push
around it you know and the more valuable
the interview is I'm gonna promote it
like crazy if it's not that interesting
doing I kind of like barely put it out
there I'm just kind of like yeah here
you guys go you know but if I love it I
tell my team like we got to make three
inspirational videos around this we're
gonna make like all the quote cards like
everything and blow it up and really wow
the person so they'll share it that's
what we really try to focus on well
you've got the internet figured out try
man no I'm trying to catch up to your
design quality you know yeah I like that
you know I'm lagging in terms of like
how I how I utilize and leverage the
internet I mean I don't know you know I
just I could probably benefit from
putting a little more energy and thought
into it but you know I don't know I have
to guess what feels right to me yeah so
I think I think less about it when you
when you look back on how many episodes
have you done now 540 yes I like you've
like you started two months after me but
I'm at there's a moment she come on I
think I'm at 320 or something like that
so you put out like quite a few more you
do monday-wednesday interviews and then
like a five-minute story I'm starting to
do more stories like metaphors parables
things like that Rama come on come here
girl fine she's fun and the story is
actually really effective because I'm
also like there's only so many things I
can come up with myself and like inspire
or motivate and so I'm trying to find
more stories that I didn't even think of
that are just great stories that people
that can relate to people's lives right
now and it's been really effective so
well when you look back on those 500
plus episodes like what did you like
what what mistakes do you think other
already talked about like do you think
back and like I wish I hadn't done that
or I could have saved a lot of time or
I wish outed them videos sooner mm-hmm
because when you started that and you
were like spend a lot of money a lot of
money man over here all the full time
editor I mean was a lot and just trying
to build up YouTube and all these things
I started at the end of last year so
about a year a little over a year and a
half of the video but I remember like
Jonathan fields had a video podcast
starting and then he switched to just
audio I know he still audio I believe
and I remember being like gosh
everyone's just going audio because it's
so much work and I was like that's why I
think I need to do video because not
many people are doing it and it gives me
another piece of content I can share on
Facebook and YouTube and build other
channels
so I'll just decided to invest in it but
in terms of I was showed you know I
remember thinking like this was gonna
take off I just had a feeling
cuz I was talking to Derek Halpern and
Pat Flynn and a few other people who had
podcasts back in 2012 2011 and I
remember like hearing them say like wow
this is starting to pick up like before
there was any news about podcasts or
before cereal and all these things
they're like this is picking up for me
like I didn't expect it to be and it's
picking up and I just felt like this was
around you know four or five years ago
this is when smartphones everyone was
getting an iPhone it was more accessible
podcast apps more accessible for people
and I was like I think it's good to take
off mm-hmm you came out with it a few
other John Lee Dumas came out with and
around the same time I think maybe a few
months before you and I was just like
I'm gonna do a podcast and I told myself
I'm not gonna listen to anyone show I
think what I did well was not listen to
anyone elses mm-hmm I couldn't either
hurt me or help me I think it helped me
because I was like I came from a place
of what's the thing I would want to hear
how would I want to hit the intro the
reads everything how would the flow be
if I was a listener and so I wasn't
skewed one way or another to what other
people did and I wasn't influenced I
just said I'm gonna create the podcast
I'd want to listen to and I'm grateful
for that I think I don't if I change
much maybe have nice or equipment early
on and you know do video but I didn't
know what was gonna happen now I'm
you know you grow into it and you evolve
you know what I mean I think that's an
important lesson for anybody who's
looking to create anything like go back
and look at that person's first whatever
I mean like you listen to my first
episode your first episode you look at
anybody you know any filmmakers first
video on YouTube whatever like you'll
realize like there's an arc and it's
okay you know you don't have to have it
all figured out and when people ask me
what's my gear it's like I don't usually
answer Matt like first of all you can
figure that out on the Internet in five
minutes it's not about that you know
it's about like what is it that you're
you want to express and to start doing
that and if it if it clicks for you
you'll figure out the rest and you'll
grow into it that's it yeah I didn't
know how I was gonna do I was like I'm
gonna do it for a year once a week and
see how it does mm-hmm and then I was
like okay I'm gonna do another year
twice a week so what where do you see it
going just keep doing it or you have a
blue growing like I feel like it's it's
gonna continue to grow but it's harder
to grow as well because there's so many
other podcasts yeah I mean if we were
starting now forget about it would be so
hard by now
so hard but there's podcasts that are
launching right now that are getting to
the top and staying there because
they're so different so unique and
that's great
I think that's great you know bring more
awareness to the podcast please yeah I
don't know I feel like I personally I
want to be just a couple years ahead of
the curve or what everyone else's is
willing to do because podcasting when we
did it was hard to do not people weren't
doing it because they didn't understand
it it was still challenging to get it up
and I was just like in a couple of years
this is going to take off I just had
that feeling like it's gonna take off
and so I'm thinking of okay how can I
continue to make this the foundation and
grow the podcast but leverage it into
other things like books and other talk
shows TV shows documentaries Netflix
shows things like that where I can find
and curate talent and information and
then build something even more beautiful
around that one piece of content but
what's that one person I could do a
documentary on that could be another
multi-million dollar brand or a book
series or something that's different
than people it's hard to write a book
you know it takes a couple years takes a
while to launch it to do the whole
traditional published thing thing it's
challenging most people aren't willing
to do that stuff most people aren't
willing to do documentaries like your
friends have done and that's where I
want to start going into because I
believe that content we can continue to
create powerful meaningful content and
spend a little bit of money into it to
make it even better and stand out that's
gonna be the difference-maker
mm-hmm so are you actively developing
some projects like that I'm in the
middle of a documentary right now yeah I
mean I hired a film crew they've they're
they've been filming the last couple
months of a process one my live event
and remember the movie the secret mm-hmm
so I'm kind of doing the secret on
steroids but mainstream not like woooe
mm-hmm and I'm developing that right now
where you know this is the ten year
anniversary of me getting injured
playing professional football it's
actually a month ago when I got injured
ten years ago and I'm doing I did this
big event in Columbus Ohio called the
summit of greatness so I brought my
entire movement back to Columbus where
I'm from and then I'm launching a book
here in the next month and then I'm
getting an award for the philanthropy
philanthropist of the Year award for
pencil promise in December and I'm
working on a few other projects in
between so I was just like I want to
capture all this three months like the
press the book tour like the doctor the
the events everything and I think it's
gonna mostly be tailored around this
event because we had some unbelievable
footage and great content we did
sit-down interviews with every speaker
or with them on stage with the attendees
got stories of the attendees so I think
there's something there you know Tony
Robbins did great with his documentary
I'm not your guru and then my friends I
think you know Joshua feels Milburn
mm-hmm from minimalism yes there doc did
great crushed it blew them up blew them
up I don't know if he I don't know if
it's public they're the numbers but
essentially they almost 10x their
download numbers their podcast exploded
employees of that as they had it for a
while and then suddenly there they were
back in the top 40 or 50 on other lines
eight months yeah and they said it's
because of the documentary on Netflix
and their book tours were sold out at
all
around the world and everything and I
was like yeah these two guys in our
space I think did it well Tony Robbins I
heard I don't know the numbers but I
heard it tripled his business since
documentary came out from his events to
everything else his courses everything
and then minimalism those guys just
crushed with that and I think they're
doing another documentary so I think
that is a space that is so untapped
because it won't moved here from Montana
car town yeah so I think Netflix what
Facebook is doing Facebook watch I'm
working on a show and developing it's
still not public yet but we're
developing a show at them right now I
think it's because it's people don't
understand how to get on Netflix it's
not like an easy thing we can just
upload a piece of content you know
you're working with agents and
distributors and all these things and
they're expensive to get a good piece of
content you know people are willing to
invest I'm willing to invest in spending
a couple hundred grand on a book
development and spending a few hundred
thousand dollars on a documentary which
may not even be anything it might just
be a marketing piece for next year's
event if I can't sell it because I
haven't sold it yet
but I just believe in this vision that
if I'm willing to invest in high quality
content and great storytelling that
moves the consciousness forward in a
positive way and helps humanity I just
believe it's gonna work out well I think
you're well on your way I mean your your
your summit of greatness was this a
third ear that you've done that second
year yeah yeah I'm gonna just seeing
clips that you shared like on Instagram
and stuff find out I post more but yeah
be crazy fun and I could see the
development from the first year already
to terms of like your production value
and all of that kind of stuff so yeah
it's cool man and fun yeah I never never
did a podcast never wrote a book before
never did a live event I was not like an
event guy never done a documentary or
movie but I'm just like I want to do
things that excite me that are
challenging but also that proved myself
that I don't have to have done something
before in order to make something
amazing and great that I can learn on
the go and I can also create something
that I would want to consume them so
again the podcast I created because it's
a thing
I wish I had growing up the book I
created because it's a wish I the book I
could have read the event is the event I
wish I could have attended all these
things and the documentary is the
documentary that I would watch that's
what I focus well that's the only only
valid way to approach any creative
endeavor I mean it has to be from the
heart and what you want to express if
you start pulling and like trying to
figure out what an audience wants that
it's not gonna work yeah exactly
yeah so who knows I take a look you know
I try to develop a magazine last year
greatness magazine I remember you
talking to me about that yeah maybe we
interviewed you for we did three full
issues that we never released we had
them all complete they look amazing
they're so beautiful
but it was like right around the time
when the Apple like magazine app or news
app transition to something else and I
was just like this is taking so much of
our time so much money and I don't know
if we're gonna make any money from this
so I spent all this money in six months
of time and energy and just canned it I
was like we're just putting on pause mmm
it was like two years ago and I'm
actually thinking about resurrecting and
bringing it back for next year I'm still
we'll see I just like to do things that
don't make money but they're fun for me
you know yeah but I also feel like you
know what's the thing that will attract
the most influential people in the world
who could add value to my audience I
think having a magazine could feed the
ego of all the publicists and be like
yeah we want to get our client honors
right in this magazine right if you're
gonna put them on the cover
sure we'll give you an interview so it's
like I feel like that might be my way to
get like Will Smith of the world the
rocks that Jim carries all those people
because they'll do a magazine cover they
may never do a podcast yeah
I think Jim Carrey might might I think
Jim Carrey might be more willing to do a
long-form podcast than a magazine
interview
true yeah I tossed it on that viral did
he see the size yeah well here's the
thing I was talking to his publicist
about two or three weeks before all this
stuff came out because I've been trying
to get him on for a while and I really
he's been one of my top three since I
started the podcast I would love to
interview him because I think would be
fascinating
and I was on the phone with his
publicist we were like she was like I
might better make it happen I was like
I'll do whatever it takes I was offering
like $10,000 to donate to his charity I
was like whatever because I believe
someone like that the information that
we do together is gonna impact for so
many millions of people that it's worth
me investing just to be able to spread
some type of positive message and it's
like it's worth it to me yeah so what
happened he was on he was going like the
Toronto Film Festival or something and
he was like maybe we can have it happen
there and I was like I'll pay you more
if we can do it in LA so I don't have to
travel and I've been following up and
she doesn't come back to me so that was
it well you know these things are you
know like timing is so important timing
these things like you know I've done
interviews that took me two years to you
know it's a schedule it because you and
I we do we only do them live right so
it's like you know when's the person
gonna be here and are you available or
when you're you know whatever like it
just these things are percolating all
the time there's the biggest guess you
got that you try to get for a long time
you're like I don't know I had a few
that I'm working on right now you know
who so you did you have that you're like
for two years or whatever um let's see
who uh Moby was cool as you know he was
great Travis Barker was awesome sweet I
don't know a couple people like that
Jordan like the Malibu like influencer
crowd out here so I feel like it's easy
you like a little pocket of all these
people that live out here yeah but like
it's different cuz you don't you don't
run into people on the street you know
right out out here like yeah I know
people around here and stuff like that
but that's not always how it works you
know and I learned to like I don't force
these things because I only want people
to come on if they want to because it
doesn't if they're like if they feel
like like oh they're doing a favor
something like it's not gonna be good
like I want them to be there because I
want to be yeah you know they're so I
don't I don't like pressure anybody or
anything like that and it's it's tricky
when you live in Los Angeles cuz you
meet a lot of people right and like you
can't just roll up on you know you meet
some cool person
you can't just immediately I don't know
maybe you do but like you know
I don't like I have to I play like a you
know like more of a coy yeah yeah longer
use one person I I want to get to know
the person first before there's actually
someone I went up to that I came on my
show Taye Diggs uh-huh who I saw him but
we had mutual friends and I had heard
about him through a mutual friend for a
long time so I just went up and said hey
man you know we've got a mutual friend
told me to say hi
misuk oh yeah yeah and he was like and
then I mentioned my podcast he's like I
love to come on like okay cool you know
should I fall up your publicist and he
was like here just take my cell right so
I actually went up to uh LL Cool J as a
guy want to get on and he follows me on
Instagram but he comments on my stuff
and likes my stuff uh-huh so I saw him
at a spot in LA and I went up to him
when like he was done with this meeting
and I just said hey man you know big fan
and you follow me on Instagram and this
and that I'd love to get you on my
podcast I've reached out a few times he
goes yeah I'd love to do it he's like
just send me a message I go I have you
haven't responded he doesn't see me goes
D me right now I'll get back to you so I
did and we've been you know trying to
find a time he's just like so busy but
yeah like I said you know they happen
when they're supposed to have they
happen when they're supposed to yeah all
right well let's talk about the new book
yeah the masks of masculinity
I mean before we kind of get into it in
depth you know I'm interested in what
motivated you to you know explore this
topic of masculinity and specifically
you know how you know as men you know
can be difficult and confusing to you
know understand how to communicate with
yourself and with other people and you
know the kind of way that we're raised
to wear these masks in their various
forms that prevent us from connecting
with our own emotions and thus
connecting with other people and
ultimately hamstringing our personal
development and growth so like what what
began you know what would yeah it's an
interesting step from your first book
school with greatness and then this is
kind of like a you know a much more
mindful you know soulful book yeah in
the first you know my whole life I've
always
a couple couple things of why I did this
whenever life the dog come here girl
you start petting her then she'll never
leave that's my stuff yeah you know
there's a couple things one I like to do
things that kind of shocked people about
me like I don't like to do the thing
that people think and what to do you
know I never drank in college or high
school because people said that they
thought I was gonna be like a drunk jock
and I was like okay I wanna be prove you
wrong
type of thing I was like I never wanted
to be the guy that people thought or
assumed that would do something so on
Gretchen Reubens four tendencies cause
you're a rebel yes so much of a rebel
yeah so I was one and two I want to do
things that are super meaningful to me
and challenge me and after the school of
greatness book my agent and publisher
were like okay let's do one on business
and marketing and I was like just boring
to me it just does it's not exciting to
me I was like sure I can sell a ton of
these but it wasn't what made me excited
inside or interested or curious and as I
was writing the book and really the
school grayness and really the year and
a half two years before I started
opening up more about being sexually
abused which I've talked to you about
how we talked about that about you know
just being bullied picked on just you
know and also not really having a lot of
emotional awareness in relationships I
felt like I would always get triggered
I'm sure a lot of people can relate to
that but I just never felt like I could
end a relationship gracefully I was so
afraid to be alone so what was your
strategy like cut and run and then you
know pretend the person doesn't exist or
like what when you would break up with
somebody he was like just constant back
and forth like arguing and stress and I
was like a coward always like I could
never just end it when I knew like it
was too long past you know sometimes
you're liking the out of know phase but
it's like when you know and you're like
going on for another six to twelve
months it's like okay what's going on
right and I was afraid I think I was
emotionally afraid to not have that
intimacy have that connection
have that friendship whatever it was I
was just afraid in my teens and early
20s and I went through a pretty bad
breakup when I moved here that made me
so angry all the time
made me just like go off on everyone
else in my life my business partners
playing pick-up basketball and I got in
a really bad fight where I put a guy in
a hospital because we were we were just
trash talking and fouling each other
hard and then all of a sudden it turned
into a fight in a there was zero stakes
on this pickup basketball game there was
nothing on the line it's just our egos
flared up so much he actually hit me
first but then I was just was determined
to finish it like my ego was so hurt
that I was like I'm gonna ruin you and
it was about that time when the
relationship was going all over the
place I got in these fights and my I
just realized I was more and more angry
and resentful and I started to open up
about the sexual abuse I went to a
couple workshops that help me kind of
open up and start talking for the first
time in 25 years and I realized wow my
entire life I've come from a place of I
need to be right and I need to win and
in order for me to be right and meet a
win that means everyone else needed to
lose and everyone else needed to be
wrong so zero-sum game and someday I'm
compulsion that comes from where yeah
like what is the genesis of where that
come from need to like you know be the
better man a number of the events you
know being sexually abused I was picked
last on sports teams all come on dude
you must have been the biggest kid nerd
I was and I was athletic but I was like
in the special needs classes in schools
and I was always had the you know it was
me and like four kids with like in a
wheelchair and it was like always they
associated me as like the dumb stupid
kid and so then when I hang out with me
so there's more of like just bullying me
or just kind of picking on me because I
wasn't able to read and write well and
had a stutter and all these other things
and it was just like I was just like the
awkward tall goofy looking kid that
picked on and again my story is not
unique because I think a lot of people
were picked on for whatever they had
going on growing up but that my brother
went to prison when I was eight years
old for four and a half years so I would
visit him in a visitor visiting room at
the prison
every every Saturday or Sunday and we
should point out just for the listener
that your brother has has transcended
that experience yes I'm a very
accomplished yeahthere's greatest jazz
violinist in the world down it's an
amazing story we're actually writing a
book about that so I think those events
a lot of that and also my parents were
kind of just arguing and fighting a lot
and I never felt seen as the youngest of
four my siblings were much older it was
kind of like the left I was just like
there by myself a lot growing up so I
didn't have friends when my brother was
in prison really because the
neighborhood parents didn't want their
kids to hang out with me because I
thought I was bad like my brother right
you know I was in this practice I
associate yeah so kind of all these
things I was just always alone you I
felt alone you know my parents were
there they loved me but it's the story I
told myself and I remember after getting
picked last on the dodgeball in a
dodgeball game was two team captains who
were boys and they picked all the guys
first and then they picked all the girls
second and then I was the last pick and
I remember saying myself like I'm never
gonna be picked last again and I'm gonna
prove all these kids wrong and the whole
world wrong about Who I am
I just kind of made that decision so
every day from that moment forward it
was me versus the world I had to be the
biggest fastest strongest person that
everything I did I had to just protect
myself so that no one could hurt me
anymore
as this kid that's how I felt and as I
evolved in high school you know people
who now became very valuable in sports
my was so you throw yourself into sports
and football selfs is your outlet to be
able to express this anger it is a safe
contained way yes but usually you know
that that wound that you describe it
comes with that inability to be intimate
with other people because you've been
hurt in that way like you're not going
to get too close to anybody and the
minute you do
get close it gets scary and you break it
off absolutely because it's too
threatening because you're because it
then you have to be vulnerable and that
puts you in a position to be hurt and
you can't have that because you know
what that's like right you gotta cut it
off and be in control of that situation
to protect yourself yeah exactly so I
think a number of those events kind of
made me feel well here's that here's the
thing about it these masks that men wear
drive us to be to achieve to achieve
something we want for me I wanted to be
a great athlete so I put on this athlete
mask and it was hard to take it off at
times but I would achieve all my
athletic goals that I had for myself and
be unhappy after I achieve them and I
didn't understand why I was unhappy Iran
fulfilled and so I would go after bigger
goals and bigger dreams and then I would
achieve those thinking they would make
me happy and they wouldn't and I was
like what why isn't why am I not happy
still and I just thought this was the
way of life until about four years ago
when I started to just heal from this
process like I never told people that I
was sexually abused and never told
people about like how much it hurt me
growing up feeling these things I never
just like shared it and when I started
to share I felt like this weight with
lift off my shoulders what what brought
you to the realization that that was
what you needed to do or what gave it I
heard I didn't know was what I needed to
do I was going to this workshop actually
that's an emotional intelligence
leadership workshop and we're going
through all the things that hold us back
in our life from being great all the
difference
you know the triggers the the anger the
resentment the playing small all the
things that we told ourselves that were
holding us back from you know achieving
the the career goals financial goals the
relationship goals health goals anything
that was holding us back from being
better we address them and a lot of
these things came back from like our
conditioning with our parents and
childhood and things like that so it was
kind of like group therapy in a sense
where they did different exercises and
games to to create real-world situations
in about three days into this five-day
workshop
the trainer facilitator was like and
we've gone pretty I mean people were
crying people were like snotting like
you know there was this pretty deep like
I didn't know I really it was gonna be
that crazy but people are really going
there too intimate vulnerable places
about where they've been heard where
they were held back what they told
themselves about how they weren't good
enough whatever maybe and there was a
point after three days of this where we
addressed our parents and you know the
childhood bullies like everyone had
their own stuff we all addressed it
trainer said okay after this moment
we're moving forward we're letting go
over the past we've addressed everything
so there's no longer need to let go into
the past we're gonna start focusing on
our vision for the future what we want
to create in our life but is there
anything if so if there isn't it if you
haven't said anything you need to say
yet now's the time otherwise forever
hold your peace and I remember like this
is like to a room of like 50 of us and I
remember like it was silent and I'm kind
of like going through in my mind like
these these images is like okay my
brother going to prison I talked about
that like my parents like getting
divorced and they're fighting all the
time okay you know being bullied being
picked on I like talked about these
things and I was like at that time I was
raped when I was five in the bathroom by
another man
but I didn't know it just like it was
just like a vision that went through my
mind and I was like why have I never
shared this with anyone for 25 years was
just like hmm like I'd put it off in my
head like it wasn't that big a deal like
oh this happened and I'm just gonna put
it to the side and I remember just
saying like huh why have I never shared
it and I felt like I need to share this
I'm just like came to me I was like I
just need to share this otherwise I'll
probably never share it so I think if I
didn't have that like three days of
experience cycle leading up to this were
these like major interruptions maybe
making other people being open and
vulnerable and sharing things like it
was really a catalyst that inspired me
to be like okay it's safe enough for me
to talk about this in this context to
these 50 people and so I literally just
stood up walked through the front of the
room like I didn't raise my hand or say
like I have something to say I just
stood up and walked in front of room I
couldn't look anyone the eyes I was
looking down
carpet the whole time and he was for the
first time I shared the story when I was
five and getting raped in a bathroom and
I walked through detail by detail for
the first time in 25 years and I
remember that I just could not look up
and I was I told it like it was a movie
like I could see it I could smell it I
could taste that experience everything I
could put myself right there and I
walked back to my chair and right when I
sat down it was like I just erupted with
tears like it wasn't crying when I was
telling the story but I couldn't look
people in the eyes because I was so
ashamed when I sat down I started just
erupting like my body was shaking I
couldn't I wanted to stop it by cooling
it and luckily there was these two women
on the side of me who were just like
crying with me and holding me and was
just like I felt so ashamed but also so
relieved that I shared something that
was holding me back emotionally and I
remember running out of the room because
I was just like ashamed of myself it's
just like embarrassed and ashamed and I
was like what are these people gonna
think of me you know
and I went out side of this workshop
room out of the the hotel where the
workshop was into the kind of back
street where there was a wall at the
back street and I just put my head on
the wall an arm on the wall and it was
just crying I couldn't stop crying and I
just wanted to be alone and one by one
the men from the room came up from
behind I'll never forget this it was
really moving for me they came up from
behind and like just hugged me and
looked me in the eyes they were like
you're my hero
and it was one of them it was like I
never felt so seen in my life when these
men who are like I was judging you the
last three days just by your image and
the way you look and you're this tall
white jock and I had no clue like this
is something you've been through and it
makes me respect you more it makes me
trust you more it makes me want to
connect with you and support you however
I can
and these men were just opening up you
know some some of the men had been
sexually abused as well and opened up
for the first time they've started
sharing with me what their experience
was and they were married with kids and
no one knew and their family other guys
who didn't have that experience were
just like man I'm here for you like
thank you for sharing thank and it felt
such a like a release to be able to just
share and I started to share after this
workshop I started to share one by one
with my family which was really
challenging to do especially my mom
because she's the one who found the
babysitter and you know she felt solely
responsible is the son of your
babysitter yeah he was like a 17 year
old
yeah like son I was five so the
babysitter was like a you know 50 year
old mother who is amazing she was right
across the my elementary school her
house was across the street so I just
had to go there after school for a
couple hours while my mom was still
working until like five or six and so I
started sharing one by one my family
which was really challenging because I
was afraid they we're gonna I don't know
not love me or not accept me or whatever
and I remember talking to like a
relationship counselor actually about
you know how do I even talk to my family
about this I had no clue how do you how
do you say something to your family or
people you're close to and so that's a
whole nother process of how I was able
to start the conversations but then I I
did it with them and I was like wow I
have they have deeper love for me they
had my brother my sisters they started
opening up about things I'd never heard
about them they were like so they felt
so much more connected to me it was
amazing what our relationship has been
like since then then I started sharing
with like close friends one by one and
it was terrifying like I was terrified
every time I did with my family then its
close friends but one by one the more I
shared it the less I like teared up
about it the less I was embarrassed
about it the less I you know felt like
it had control over me it was like now I
was only the story as opposed to the
story owning me
and it didn't have power over me anymore
after like months and months of talking
about it and then I people were like you
need to share this on your podcast and I
was like no [ __ ] way there's like no
way that I want the world to know this
about me cuz I was still terrified and
then the more I said that I was like hmm
the story must still own me if I'm not
willing to reveal myself to everyone but
everything I've been through yeah you're
still afraid there we go is in the way
what are people gonna think about me I
gotta follow me still they're gonna you
know or they gonna think it's some
marketing thing I'm doing or whatever
like I was just scared and remember it
took me about six months to finally
agree to doing it and I and I recorded
it with Jonathan fields and he kind of
interviewed me to go through the process
and that was pretty scary I really you
know during it I was very kind of
nervous still and now I can talk about
it where it doesn't own me but what I
realized is when I published this
podcast about being sexually abused and
kind of the whole process and what was
available on the other side for me was
freedom was intimacy was not feeling
afraid anymore of what people thought
about me not feeling like people are
judging me anymore because I've put
everything out there and a deeper sense
of inner peace like I just felt at peace
of my heart
whereas I always felt angry and
passive-aggressive when I had these
triggers and so what I realized is like
when I post this I had hundreds of
emails from men and women but so many
men that opened up to me for the first
time being sexually abused or just going
through some challenge in their life
where they felt like wow if you could do
this and share about your thing then
maybe I can share about my thing with my
sister or my parents or my wife or
whatever it may be you know it's just
like man I thought I was like the only
one who wasn't talking about this but I
guess everyone isn't talking about like
the things they're most ashamed of or
what they're afraid of
and that said huh there's something here
it was like the most downloaded episode
it was the most shared is the most
meaningful the most impactful and I was
like this is the topic not necessarily
around sexual abuse but why do men wear
different mass
that hold them back why do man cause a
lot of resentment and anger and conflict
in relationships with business friends
family intimate partners why do we do
this as men not all men but why in
general do some men do this and I
realize that you know a lot of this
conditioning over time from your parents
saying like you know don't cry don't be
a crybaby be a man be this when your
coaches be a man get back up don't show
pain from you know the confusion of
relationships where women want a bad guy
and they're you know the bad guys are
rewarded in high school too then they
want a sensitive person but then they
want you to be strong you want you to
show you so it's like constantly
conflicting and I think yes we all have
our own responsibilities to be the best
person we can be but when society
culture family friends girlfriends
teammates are starting to have this
pressure constantly to feel accepted we
need to be a certain way to fit in we
have to fit in with to what they want us
to be not who we truly are and being
open honest and vulnerable is completely
at odds with that and our whole lives
and you know look this is applicable to
women - absolutely
but I think it's a little bit more acute
with men because of the way we're sort
of socially conditioned and programmed
as we as we grow into these gender roles
but the idea that you're gonna be honest
and open about your flaws and your
failures and and be vulnerable and
expose yourself in that way runs
contrary to everything we were talking
up and you know I wasn't sexually abused
but I have my version we first thought
this I have my version of this through
alcoholism and addiction recovery and
and one of the most downloaded episodes
I ever did is when I talked about
relapsing after I had had a lot of time
and after I had completed writing
functional ultra and before I had come
out and I was deeply ashamed of that
because I was like oh my god I wrote
this book about addiction recovery you
know and my journey to wholeness and
Here I am still this perfection
incredibly flawed human being what
that mean and what are people gonna
think and I held on to that for a long
time I mean first of all just being an
alcoholic in general like my journey to
being able to own that came through
variety and recovery and Rehab and you
know everything that I put into creating
a foundation of sobriety where that
story doesn't control me anymore like I
own it and I'm totally comfortable
talking about it and I've had that same
experience where when you can when
people know when you're comfortable
about it and they're like they're not
used to that and they're like oh wow
like it's not so bad like maybe I can
share that thing that I'm scared about
or be a little bit more vulnerable than
I happen but there's always more layers
you know and so like when I relapsed I
was like well I owned that but like this
is still owning me right and I had to do
the same thing and share it on my
pockets was terrifying
you know revived but that was the thing
that you know people really connected
with that and they didn't have to be an
alcoholic or an addict but just the fact
that like I was willing to be that
honest I think gives people it connects
it connects you to people and like you
look but brené Brown talks about this
beautifully and I know you just
interviewed her and like she's my hero
she's amazing amazing and you know if
you do anything in the wake of this
podcast other than re-read Lucis book
please explore the work of brené Brown
because she's really you know dug into
the research on this and the truth is
we're terrified of being vulnerable yeah
because we equate it with weakness but
the truth is that is your strength and
if you can muster the courage to be
vulnerable and to like own your path and
it's a journey to getting to there but
when you can get to that place where it
doesn't control you anymore
it is incredibly empowering and it's the
thing that that is gonna connect you
with other human beings and like infuse
your life with meaning and purpose and
direction it's a beautiful process and
it's terrifying like I'm not I'm
terrifying so so so I understand like
why we walk around with these masks on
you know the enemy we know is is much
better than the you know the mysterious
enemy that we don't right right and it's
stories like yours where you can you can
lead by example and and really
demonstrate this that that provides that
opening that
shift you know people's perspective on
these issues and give them permission to
like own their own truth yeah and that's
what I realized when I when I started
sharing more years ago four years ago
people told me that they had permission
to start opening up and the release they
had after sharing it was like they had
to weight off their shoulders mm now
they could finally step into who their
being and I feel like if we have a mask
on if we're holding something back
we are never able to get into full flow
in our lives we may be 70 80 % but until
we're in full flow which means being our
authentic self we could never have the
highest impact or achieve the greatest
results in our life we're a little bit
tight or live a little bit clenched you
can't you know be an athlete if you're
clenched you can't be an athlete of life
if you're closed off so I realize like
wow so many men are hurting and in the
American society and yes suffering
silently suffering now quote Henry David
Thoreau I exactly cuz it's not it's not
okay so okay to talk about it right
can't talk about on with your boys you
can't talk about with girls you can't
talk about your wife because when you do
they tell you you know in general that's
I say well I need you to be strong right
now because I'm all over the place and
so it's like there might have been one
time you were told like no you can't I
need you to be strong for me right now
where the man thought okay I got to be
strong all the time then you know maybe
and you know I love brené Brown I love
Oprah I love the people are talking
about vulnerability because it's
transformed a lot of women's lives who
feel like they can share but a lot of
men aren't listening to burn a brown
right who are unless they're like you
know yoga socially conscious men but the
guys that I grew up with in general they
most likely want to be caught in the
barbecue and NFL I just wanted best or
whatever like yeah they're not like
let's see what Brunei has to snow
they'll never watch that ugh talk and I
remember when I started getting into her
work four years ago and learning more
about this and learning about
vulnerability and things I was like wow
this is so powerful and yet no not many
guys are talking about it and so I just
felt like I had a response you can't
really a cipher for that I felt like I
had a responsibility like I look like
the
typical jock I'm a tall white man you
know and I've had some distance success
I've had some other success in my life
as an athlete so if I could be a Trojan
horse or a catalyst to get people and to
get men and to be like hey you want to
live a great life get open up if you
want to cheat you want to make a lot of
money you want to get the girl you want
to be a great athlete like okay you can
do that and you don't have to suffer you
don't have to constantly live in this
prison inside of your mind and
constantly come from aggressive place or
win-lose place you know I need me to be
right all the time like that creates so
much disease in our hearts and when we
can come from a place of how can I win
and how can you win and everyone around
me win like it just feels better when we
come from place of you know maybe I'm
not right here let's let's just hear it
out let's have a discussion and and see
what we come up with together
you're not isolating yourself by being
the only winner and the only person
who's right you're not being an island
by yourself in that place now you're
connecting to a larger community of
people and you're supporting humanity as
opposed to creating the conflict that
we're seeing so much in the world today
I think is a starting place the
individual has to at least be in a place
where they're willing to kind of wrestle
with their demons a little bit I mean
I'm just scary man to work you're saying
oh the typical guy all right like let's
conjure the stereotype yeah like often
that guy's so disconnected from his
emotional body because of that
programming and because of the coaches
or the parent whatever it is that
they're not even aware that there were
pressing their emotions because that
disconnection is so complete so strong
so how do you even like mask is few nice
couple faces yeah like there's no
distinction between the mask and the
person like my wife my wife there's
there's one particular type of mask that
my wife calls the super duper 'he's like
when you meet you know you meeting I'm
sure in your business circles you meet
guys like this all the time they're like
when you meet them and they give you
that super firm handshake and they look
you in the eye you like how you doing
they're a super cute props I'm so I'm
super I'm sorry you do
you know and you're like [ __ ] you
know guys not this guy's not even in the
universe of beginning to be honest with
me about however he's feeling maybe
that's not the right context or maybe he
would be you know more open in a
different setting but in general it's
like a guy who's walking around like
that all the time he's just I mean the
mask is so obvious right and it's such a
barrier because you're like alright well
am I really gonna have a meaningful
conversation with Scott probably not
like I'll just go through the niceties
and like move on yeah yeah yeah you know
I just feel like now's the time with
more and more conflict and the politics
with more more conflict with the racial
issues that are happening just seems
like everyone that's fighting at least
and now is public with social media it's
just so prominent you see it so much but
if they there's got to be an
interruption and the only way to take
the mask off is with an interruption
whether it be you know a major break up
in your life a divorce a near-death
experience someone in your life
near-death experience pain in their
direction
you gotta get some type of cuz you're so
people people are so attached to their
identity yeah you're asking them to let
go of essentially like who they are like
that's a huge app for me the reason why
it happened is because I had a major
interruption I was in this five day
workshop where it took three days for me
to finally like have a mirror in front
of my face and be like oh I have an ego
I didn't think I had an ego I thought I
was just like this good guy or I wasn't
angry but I was always angry inside and
it took a deep interruption where this
facilitator just called me out of my
[ __ ] like over and over in front of
everyone he was like why are you so
angry Louis he just kept saying why are
you so angry and I was like I'm a
fun-loving like I hunted people all the
time I'm always happy I was like what do
you mean angry he was like you're really
angry it's like all over your face it's
all over your energy and I was just like
[ __ ] you y'all so he don't know me I was
like you respond with anger
exactly defend yourself and angerness
but it's just like the more and more
feedback I got I was like I started to
open up I started
cognise the the math I was wearing the
the the things that were holding me back
and I needed that interruption it took
me 30 years to have an interruption and
I think I hear this from other friends
who have near-death experiences or other
things or it's like that's their wake-up
call so it's hard because I don't want
anyone to have a near-death experience
or have to go to a workshop or any of
these things to have that interruption
that's why I think it's so important for
the women in the lives of men who have
these masks to support as a loving
interruption by not making men wrong for
wearing it because I think in a lot of
relationships I hear men saying my
girlfriend my wife makes me wrong for
who I am and it's constantly nagging me
these things so I think women can play a
part in being a loving interruption by
coming from a place of love and
understanding by first being aware like
why is he wearing this mask as opposed
to just making him wrong for who he is
let me look deeper and this is hard to
do when you're frustrated with your man
for him being a certain way after years
I get it it's really hard to do as a
woman to to kind of step into this
loving awareness of understanding but I
think if you want to see a
transformation in the manager and your
your life your father your brother your
husband boyfriend sons it's a lot of
mothers out there talking about their
sons how they're disconnected it's like
trying to come from a place of Y first
that they might be doing that that's why
we try to create the information on why
someone might be wearing that mask and
then some tools and resources on how to
get them to take off the mask for a
moment so you can have a intimate
conversation with them the best way to
do that that I found is through
acknowledgement acknowledging the your
son your husband the boyfriend your dad
for the good they are doing focus on
those good moments in the life where
they do show a tender side are they
there they are thoughtful or they are
open and just say I really appreciate
how you did that you know the other day
with so-and-so it was so beautiful to
see and it just made me feel so much
more connected to you and made me want
to have incredible sex with you whatever
it is you got to say to like get them
excited and encourage that as opposed to
encouraging the mass or making the mass
wrong because when you make them out
wrong you're probably gonna push the man
away or make them want to keep the mask
on tighter to protect themselves so it
should be aware of that yeah that's
interesting I mean I'm as you're saying
that I'm sort of you know reflecting
back on my own path with this and and
the role that that Julie played and you
know she was always like she could tell
I was suffering like being a lawyer
pretty like wearing a certain mask and
trying to make it work even though it
was at odds with this person that she
could always see this better version of
me but I was too afraid to you know step
in that direction and too afraid to let
go of the mask I was wearing and what
did she did it was well she just she was
like I believe in you and like no more
than this and you know I have a vision
for you like just you know you need to
trust your instincts like you're
suffering like let me help you or and
then at other times like just giving me
space like like she was you know she
went through like look here's what you
need to do and then that didn't work you
know what I mean it's like I don't want
to hear somebody telling me what I
should you judge me or did she just let
go and and you know ultimately she got
to a place of like look I love you
unconditionally like you want to keep
living that way I'd still want to be
married to you and I love you and we'll
have a great life I think there's you
know you have more potential to do
things in other areas but you know this
is your life like she's like I'm
releasing you to your life like I am
releasing you like I'm sorry for vibing
you or for trying to come you know
feeling like I wanted you from there you
are like and it wasn't like a it wasn't
like like a strategy like she really
meant it like I could tell that it was
real like she wasn't just saying it you
know like she was she felt that in her
heart and I and I noticed that shift and
and I think that is what like you talked
about like suddenly seeing yourself in
the mirror like that is what allowed me
to actually see myself as I was in the
mirror because I had to then take
responsibility for myself not to please
somebody else or my partner yeah right
and I think that was a huge catalyst and
my growth but you know these things are
hard and and you know pain you know it's
like that pain moment like if you if
that happens to you
that's a gift you know as maybe as
terrible as the circumstances may be
there's a there's a divinity and that if
you can grab on to that and understand
that it's a it's a moment that you can
grab on to and harness to begin this
journey that you've experienced and it
can be a beautiful thing but you know
these masks come in many forms and you
kind of you know you outline the book
and break them down you have like nine
masks
Joker mask and the stoic mask and the
invincible masked aggressive mask the
athlete mask the sexual mask the
know-it-all mask the Alpha mask I mean
just by their titles you can kind of
imagine how these these things break
down right but they're all powerful and
I don't think anybody Falls I mean
certainly there's a spectrum and you
know you kind of okay the Alpha mask I
kind of know who that guy is but I think
most men are a hybrid of a number of
these you know and I think you know what
you did well in the book was that you
entered this as a learning experience
for yourself it's not like hey this is
this is the way that it is and this is
what you need to do it's like I
struggled with this and in each chapter
when you're kind of breaking down these
various masks you're like this is what I
this is how I wore this mask or here's
an example of like where I kind of went
awry because of some example something
that happened in your life and I think
it'll aoz people that kind of connect
with that yeah I mean I'm pretty much in
every chapter I talk about all my faults
ability however worn every mask how it
supported me in my life and how it
didn't support me so again I'm not
trying to come from a voice of like
you're a wrong man if you wear a mask or
you're bad it's not about right and
wrong good and bad it's about what's
effective and what's working and what's
not working and are you suffering inside
by wearing this mask it's something
holding you back from living a fuller
richer life and your relationships your
health your spiritual health everything
and if something is holding you back
let's address it let's look at it for
instance the material mask for me save
my life in a sense because when I was
broke on my sister's couch I fixated on
making as much money as I could so I
could get off the couch
so I said I'm gonna become a master I'm
making money I no longer want to feel
broke I want to feel like I have
abundance in my life financially so I
spent the next year and a half two years
only thinking about money and I gained
60 pounds and I had no intimate
relationships but it got me to make it
to make a lot of money so it's like okay
it supported me in some ways to getting
the goal that I had in mind
but I left me feeling so unfulfilled in
the rest of my life so it's like how can
we balance this and be aware and take it
off in certain times the scary yeah no I
get that and I think the thing that that
happens I think is that guys get in
their Lane right and if you you take a
successful guy maybe he's wearing the
material mask maybe he's wearing the
athlete mask whatever it is he's
excelled in his life and if you were to
ask that person they will tell you the
reason that they excelled is because of
the mask and now you're proposing that
they let go of that and as that means
that they'll no longer be able to do the
thing that they do right yeah and that's
the fear and that's the unknown yeah so
yeah so it's a leap of faith mm-hmm and
as somebody who's taken that leap
yourself and I have as well we can both
say like look the water's warm on the
other side it's gonna be okay like
that's an illusion that attachment to
that identity
yeah and that strategy and that mask is
although you think it's serving you it
actually isn't but you're gonna have to
trust me
mmm-hmm it's hard and here's the thing
you know it's like let's use the
material mask for an example like I'm
all about having nice huh nice things
like living in a nice place flying
first-class like I'm all about
convenience and all these things but I
think if I was posting about all my
material possessions every single day on
social media talking about how much
money I had constantly I would attract a
certain crowd and I would attract people
close to me who probably were thinking
about the same things were focused on
the money so I would ask myself like if
I didn't if I lost it all well those
friends still be around
did I make an impact in their life or
did I have meaningful connections with
them beyond the money
was that the thing that attracted them
to me as well so these need to ask
yourself like again if you're an athlete
and then you get injured your friends
gonna stick around is your entourage you
to stick around if you're no longer
playing in the game whatever supports
your playing you no longer have the
money did you make an impact in people's
lives did you build meaningful intimate
relationships if you didn't those people
probably aren't gonna stick around but
don't don't allow your your net worth to
reflect your self-worth and the same
thing with your athletic capabilities
and everything else figure out a way to
develop your self-worth first and build
meaningful value in other people's lives
and if you make a lot of money cool but
at least you have the foundation first
of self worth
yeah the tricky thing is is like most
rich dudes are either there's that's
what their self-worth is wrapped up in
it's on their bank account like yeah if
their bank account goes down it's like
they have a heart attack and it doesn't
matter that it's not solving the
happiness equation because there's
always one more thing to get because the
other guy has it and you don't always
you'll chase that I mean look we've got
life right you were well all your life
we live in Hollywood you know it's like
those guys are all around I know
look I know tons of millionaires and you
know billionaire type guys that are not
happy people you know but they still
there on that treadmill you know and
it's gonna take you know something
pretty severely relative to get them off
of that and reevaluate who's the guy who
lives up here the famous director who
lived in a massive match and he actually
directed all the Jim Carrey Tom Shadyac
along now who's in like a trailer park
yeah didn't lift a boulder for a while
he's he's back I've been trying to get
him on the public eye was amazing yeah
but he yeah he made an amazing
documentary it's called I am NOT I think
it's called I am NOT that or something
like that and I forget the name David do
you know that documentary I'm talking
about I forget the name of it something
like that but basically yeah one of the
biggest Directors in Hollywood
had everything national directing giant
you know comedies with all the big movie
stars Jim Carrey etc and just was like
dude it's not you know the real
happiness no not at all and he just
basically quit being a director
sold all his belong
moved into a moved into a trailer in
Malibu this trailer yeah it's like yeah
I know like there's a there's a little
area in Malibu where it's like it it's
like technically it's a trailer park but
these are like amazing trailer you know
nice right a paradise go so I think it's
not huge it's like the size of this no
they're like yeah they're small they're
but they're cool you know it's not like
you live a nice film oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah but anyway but it's an incredible
documentary where he kind of you know
talks about all these things yeah I'm
gonna watch that's not true I mean look
we know it intellectually like everybody
knows my name isn't buy you happiness
bother but it's like but actually
believing that and like we sort of go
yeah yeah yeah but like if I just get
the testicle bites it buys your
convenience advise you like a more
comfortable life advising these other
things that you know lack of money can't
get you but it doesn't buy you inner
peace and I think that's the thing as
men we struggle with is finding this
sense of like inner peace and inner
fulfillment and if we're constantly
chasing something thinking that it's
gonna give us inner peace without
addressing the things that are holding
that peace back from us that's where we
get into trouble so it's how can we
address those things now and then go
make billions of dollars but and you're
to be happier but you got to be willing
to go on that journey of self-discovery
and you're gonna have to get used to the
idea of being open and vulnerable you
know like and a lot of these things date
back to these childhood wounds so you
know I interviewed this guy in the
podcast Cabramatta who's an expert in
addiction and his whole thing is you
know so many addicts like it's rooted in
these childhood traumas and and even
when you look back on your life in
you're like well I wasn't abused and my
parents weren't alcoholics but there's
some sign of their psychic damage
there's emotional trauma they're left
unresolved or left unaddressed and
unexamined it's toxic in your life and
it's manifesting in these behavior
patterns and these these sort of
mentalities that are you know that get
firmer and firmer as we age and and and
form the very basis of our identity that
ultimately are leading us astray from
the thing that we seek most which is
purpose and meaning satisfaction and
you know and and and to love and to be
loved yeah right and and and we're all
chasing it in the wrong directions and
it's confusing because as men I think
it's in certain respects and I'm
interested because you're so much
younger than me and what you think about
this like you know the great generation
the World War two veterans like look
this you be this is what you do is a man
like it was pretty clear-cut there
wasn't a lot there was nobody was
writing books
the mask of masculinity and then Vietnam
happened and we have the 60s and there's
an openness and it's the flower
generation and then we have Gen X and
all the angst that gets built into that
Gen Y now we have the Millennials and so
the Millennials are this generation of
people who are you know by their very
nature not to be overly stereotypical
but more in touch with their emotions
I'm talking about men as much as women
it's a it's a permissive generation in
which you know it's okay for dude
friends to like share intimate details
of their life in a way that like perhaps
was not okay in my generation and
generations that preceded me but also I
would imagine there's also that that
conflicting expectation that you know
the dude still has to be strong and is
still you know he's gotta be the
gentleman and he has to be the warrior
and he has to be yeah this year dad he's
going to all the things at the school
but he's also got to be the provider
who's making sure that he's free you
know and he's got to be sensitive and so
there it's like I'm calm and I like it
like there's all of these halogen yeah
and like it's not this is not a pity
party for men like I say to the Charter
for women all of these things apply to
them yes exactly
looking gender expectations that create
like a sense of vertigo because you
can't be all of those things all the
time how does that balance out and like
what is the path forward in terms of
like being self actualized and authentic
to who you are
yeah so that's the equation right I
think what's the solution Louis come on
you wrote the book the solution is to
first be aware of the mask that you're
wearing
first be aware is - okay well and be
aware and say why am I doing this why
and start to journal like what are the
things that I still hold on to what are
the things that I don't like talking
about what are the things that I get
triggered around and start to have it
written down on a piece of paper in your
journal and be aware of it but like okay
here are some things it's good to know
it's good to be aware the next thing is
like saying okay what's the next step
for me how am I get about to move past
this who do I need to talk to about this
would be my guy friend girlfriend wife
parents whatever it is who do I need to
address and clear things with so that
these things don't own me anymore but
I'm in control of them mm-hmm I think
that's a great first step and it's an
ongoing process listen I wrote the book
on this but it's like I still wear these
masks you know it's not like I'm like
this perfect actualized aware sensitive
loving vulnerable man 24/7 I get
triggered like the best of them that's
why I have daily practices of meditation
which I know you do of gratitude of
looking into people's eyes and
connecting with them I also constantly
in appreciation I'm always saying how
much I appreciate people throughout my
day throughout my experiences I mean
coming from a place of gratitude
gratitude allows me to just be focused
on the little small things that I'm
appreciating as opposed to fixating of
things I'm ungrateful for or the things
that trigger me or the things that make
me meet matter aggressive it's those
little daily practices that really got
me and also surrounding myself with a
good team that I say hey listen give me
feedback if I'm being aggressive if I'm
being this if I'm being whatever give me
feedback in a loving way don't get mad
at me because that's gonna make me
trigger more but just let me know in a
loving way like hey I feel like you're
disconnected from us right now and so I
have a really good team you know I would
say my personal life team and also my
business team they're all grounded
people who give me great feedback I
think it's you know setting yourself up
the best way you can because we're gonna
go through a lot of challenges for the
rest of our life especially if you're up
to a big game in life you're gonna go
through challenges in adversity so just
try to set yourself up to win and
and don't beat yourself up so much for
having these things like don't put
yourself down more now that you're aware
of these things be like okay how can I
be at peace with this how can I let it
go and be aware of it so next time it
comes up I see the mask on and I take it
off quicker and that should be our goal
mm-hmm yeah I think that's pretty good
practical advice you know IIIi think
it's important as a first step if you're
suffering or you have some level of self
awareness of some dissonance within you
or some behavior pattern that that you
know is unhealthy but you're not sure
what's behind it I think the first thing
is to find somebody that you trust to
speak to yeah and and and to find
somebody who you can confide in okay and
honestly and like tell like really
honest and open as you possibly can
feels so much better when you've got to
release that gotta share yeah and it's
that's tough if you've never done that
because it requires you to trust
somebody you know and I and I honestly
don't think and I'm sure you don't you
dull a lot of like therapy or recovery
stuff I'm assuming but I don't think we
can heal until we start to share instead
we took another belies you're only as
sick as your secrets
that's the one hangman yeah and so
you've got to find that and I think it's
I think journaling is super important
and there's all kinds of exercises that
I've that I've you know done over the
years one thing that's really powerful
is to kind of inventory certain
situations and interactions you have so
let's say your anger flares up or you
end up in a fight with your girlfriend
or boyfriend or something happens at
work like to actually do an honest and
open inventory of what exactly happened
and try to see and own your part in that
like because everybody kind of comes out
of those situations blaming the other
person or being a victim or like this
day to dad and they did this but like
let's get really honest about like what
your pardon that was and the more you
get into the habit of doing that
patterns start to emerge and you start
to go oh I see like when this happens
like I always get anger angry or this is
how I react like why am i doing that and
can like catalyze a more of a deeper
inquiry into like what's behind that and
then you can begin to unpack that and
that I think that's you know another
first step and starting to resolve it
and heal it you know to find somebody to
trust so I mean there's a million you
know it's like it's not it's like
there's no one there's no right way or
one way it's like the what's the way
that you're gonna do you know what I
mean is it gonna be group therapy is it
seeing a therapist is it just like going
on a bike ride with your best friend and
finally mustering the courage to tell
him what's going on or her whoever you
know that you know that that matters
less than simply getting into the
mindset and and the behavior of actually
in the doing of it right you know it's
the same thing with like when you hear
about these stories of men or women
coming out of the closet it's like they
held onto this tension and this
resentment and this anger for their
whole life and then they finally open up
about it and it's like you can literally
see them look younger feel lighter you
know feel happier about anymore
fulfilled because they're finally
stepping into who they've always been
there they are bringing their their
their identity into alignment with their
itself in alignment with their inwards
it's it so it's like we all have
something that we might be holding back
from or not be willing to share fully
but I believe when we start to fully
share that thing that we that you know
it's either who we are or the things
we've been through that we're scared to
share that's when we can fully step into
a lighter more fulfilled life yeah when
I was in rehab part one of the Halloween
rehab for a hundred days dude Wow
like alone in a facility or with like a
group of people well it was it was in a
facility just with them with your print
phases at well there was family week
that was super fun where they come up
and they confront you with all the [ __ ]
it was it was super intense but after I
was there like maybe 60 or 70 days then
I kind of moved out of the like dorm
into like a house that was a couple
blocks away like and I
a little bit more freedom but no I was
essentially like my best thinking got me
confined to a mental institution and I
stayed there for a hundred days but like
you know I was in bad shape when I
arrived there I thought I'll be here for
a couple weeks you know I gotta get back
to my job man you know like I got a big
important life waiting out here like
yeah I got this problem but like I got a
spin-dry cuz you don't understand like
you don't understand my responsibility
you know and they're like yeah yeah yeah
and and it was terrifying and I was
fully aware that like you know look this
was not the plan for my life like you
know I was somebody that a lot of
promise and potential as a young person
that I squandered and now here I was you
know in this situation that I was deeply
ashamed about and that's a whole other
you know it's a two-hour podcast and of
itself but my point is that I realized
the gravity of the situation and I knew
that I needed to take it seriously and
give myself over to it completely if I
really wanted to heal and resolve you
know what got me there in the first
place and one of the first things that
they had us do was write down ten
instances of of your drinking and using
like what was your intention going into
like I said my intention was I'm gonna
go and meet a couple friends and have a
couple drinks and then write what
happened I woke up in Vegas like Adam
naked in a hotel room and didn't know
where my wallet was or whatever and then
how that impacted other people like how
did this create harm to the people in
your world and then how did that harm
yourself and ten instances of that and I
was like okay I'm gonna do that
super honestly like it was the first
time but I was like honest with anybody
about like how I was actually living and
I had to read this out loud in front of
the whole group of like forty people
that were in this program and I had that
cathartic experience but also the
counselors were like yeah I think you
they're like I know you want to get out
of here in like 28 days but like yeah
like you need to stick around do like
this is pretty like you're you're pretty
far down the line
you should hang out for a while yeah and
I was like okay whatever you say man and
so that's why I ended up staying close
until you surrender yeah I surrendered
because then I tried to get sober my way
a million times like using myself well
and without taking my mask off like I'm
gonna I'm just gonna like will it will
myself into fixing this problem because
that's how I've solved every other
problem in my life and that just dug the
hole deeper and deeper and deeper until
I was so broken that was my pain moment
my dying moment and I was like I give up
like you whatever you say I'm doing what
you you know I am here 110 percent yeah
and I'm not gonna fight you I'm not
gonna ask questions or intellectualize
what you're telling me to do I'm just
gonna do trust the process because I had
no I had tried everything else I had no
other options other than to just
completely surrender to this thing and
that's what saved my life so the point
being that as scary as it is to
surrender especially for a guy because
we equate it with giving up
relinquishing our power how dare you I
know I'm not gonna really not giving up
my power I was surrendering are you
kidding me but that is where you find
the strength yeah it is in that
willingness to be vulnerable that your
greatest strength lies and you know that
is a I don't wish my experience on
anybody but the lesson of that I think
is what you're trying to convey in this
book and and it is powerful and it's
something that you know I think men all
over the world are struggling with
silently yeah so I commend you on the
book thanks brother good job I wanted it
before we wrap it up though I know you
went on this silent meditation retreat
not silent not wasn't silent but what
did you get I went to India to another
trauma it was called one world Academy
uh-huh
it was powerful I went for two weeks
didn't leave the premises of this place
and the first the second or third day I
got really sick from eating something in
another city and so for like three days
I was having like a literal spiritual
journey of like purging all these days
you know right the bad chicken I ate or
something but I had a few days of
meditation before that then I went
through I was like just in my bed
throwing up and go to the bathroom
constantly for another couple days and
then I stayed for an extra week to do to
become a meditation instructor
and both workshops were so powerful just
learning again how to deepen this
practice of like forgiveness and inner
peace and to remove suffering because I
felt like I still hadn't fully had all
the tools that I needed to like let get
with the mass and be at peace and last
year really helped strengthen my ability
to be vulnerable and be at peace and not
suffer as much now feel so guilty or
shameful about things and so meditations
been a huge plus for me I mean I've been
doing it for years but this style that I
learned and just being in an intensive
environment for two weeks where I was
you know eating vegan and on the ocean
and just disconnected from everything
was another powerful experience from a
cell where and yet was I was near
Chennai oh yeah yeah good night when the
Bay of Bengal all right it's amazing man
it's great and and what was the tech
some of the craziest they created their
own type of technique where they have
science everything is backed by science
unlike the amount of breathing you do
how you breathe if there's humming
involved like how it's there's
everything has a purpose it's not just
like okay we're just gonna breathe for
10 counts it's like no why because this
is what happens with the brain and the
body when we do these things it was all
backed by science which I liked and
there was zero to religious talk about
anything
there wasn't any connection to God God
so there is guru there's no guru Wow all
the way to India and you didn't even sit
at the mirror and there was teeth I was
there was multiple teachers uh-huh so
there was like multiple trainers you
know meditation they lived as monks so I
remember because I'm a pretty like
affectionate guy I've kind of hug
everyone and I try to like put my arms
out to hug like one of the female
teachers then they were like no no no I
was like I'm sorry so I had a fun like
teasing them the whole time like acting
like I was going to touch them but it
was more playful it was profound man we
went to some crazy places in our mind
like some they use different techniques
they use music they use you know it was
dark we would do it in the middle of the
night they would wake us up and be like
2 a.m. and we'd kind of be already be
sleepy and they would put us in these
like meditative state
and have us do different exercises and
prompts to really try to see how we can
eliminate suffering hmm and there's no
way to fully eliminate suffering but we
can be aware of it when it happens and
then move into a beautiful state quickly
and so that's what they taught us how to
do is to be there's only two states we
can live in a suffering state or a
beautiful state and the goal is to
always be in a beautiful state when
possible beautiful state of being and
you know just reconfirming these masks
we live in a suffering state when we're
wearing a mask as opposed to living in
flow which is a beautiful loving State
and that's a practice you've kept up
since you got back
for the first once I was everyday yeah I
do about 15 minutes mm-hmm just 15
minutes in the morning I can do it
anytime during the day but it's it's not
like TM when you're supposed to do it
two times a day or whatever it's just
there's and multiple meditations
multiple meditations to help people when
as an instructor when they're going
through different things actually
actively teaching people now I haven't
been teaching I've been featuring like
you know my girlfriend and stuff like
that but and I would think I would need
a lot more practice for me to feel
comfortable like facilitating larger
groups I'm sure I could kind of pull it
off and get away with it but I would
want to train some more but just more
wanted to know the deeper side of
teaching others in order to teach myself
right that's why I wanted to do the
instructor training and I'll tell you
what that time I've never been on like
drugs or medication or anything but I
felt like I was able to and I always
felt like I had a very powerful mind
like I could see visions and do things
with my mind and manifest them in my
body in the real world a man they just
took me to a whole nother level of what
was possible in terms of my thinking and
thinking so much bigger and expansive
that I've ever thought before so for me
I really appreciate that level of
expansiveness and consciousness in my
mind and then I want to go back and do
more because I feel like I was just
getting started that's pretty cool now
that's powerful
it's unbelievable academy.com how
you find like how did you select this
place founded friend of mine good buddy
of mine had done and went there for a
few days and did it and it was like its
life changing and this guy's got like
super ad D all over the place
I saw him calmer and he was like you
gotta go check this place out he was
like Tony Robbins went there a few years
ago and he there's a video of Tony
Robbins talking about it actually where
for 30 40 years Tony Robbins always
talked about in his workshops I don't
know if you've been to one he always
talks about being at a peak State he's
like you got to get in a peak State and
be peak State 24/7 if you want to create
impact and results right so we'd always
be like get peak State getting peak
State
two years ago he changed his entire
language that he's had for four decades
or whatever - it's not a peak State it's
a beautiful state and there's a
distinction it's hard to be in a peak
state 24/7 it's hard to like be ramped
well if you're at a peak state 24/7 then
there is no other state like I said I
can't be like it's a it's called a peak
for a reason exactly you know like I
yeah it's just not sustainable yeah for
the world and so he learned through this
meditation practice about being in a
beautiful state and a beautiful state
you can be in a peak state you can be
loving you can be giving it could be all
these things you're in total flow and
it's so it's crazy now you go to his
workshop he talks about let's get into a
beautiful state and he learned it from
this workshop experience and so for a
guy who's kind of like always been the
teacher for millions of people for
decades to be able to change his
philosophy I was like hmm I was just
curious to learn like what this is right
it's not led you there and how many
people were there
Wow I was probably like 20-30 there's
like 30 people and like the first week
which was like the general 5-day
meditation like beginners workshop then
I think they were like six or eight of
us in the meditation instructor training
workshop afterwards so it was it was
great man if year ago I highly recommend
it cool and yeah I'll check it out no
all right man I think we did it
let's phone man so
this is the third time I think you've
been on my podcast region your I think
so then twice right the first time and
then and then when your book came out
okay and yeah so I think is a third time
and I think I've been on yours twice two
or three times probably yeah so is our
fifth podcast good man I think it was
the best one though this is 5e it was
it's more organic the dogs barking I
know real life is happening you know it
man it's good man so we're not living
perfect here you know we're took off our
masks I know yeah I don't live in a
hermetically sealed world these Anatomy
I'm an acceptance of yes you know of
nature interferences that it's fine
those are my dogs yes anyway so the book
comes out October 19th October 31st
Halloween we take off the mask on
Halloween Halloween come as a god how
much yourself please tell me home as
your true self is this your did you come
up with that tagline Louis come as
yourselves baby okay we're gonna have a
party on Halloween that we just show up
as we are are you gonna throw a big
Halloween party now I'll probably do a
party a couple days before because
Halloween everyone's gonna want to do
something else
everybody's got a got a plan yeah well
cool so yeah you're probably about to
ramp up a ton of press you're on in New
York and doing all that kind of stuff
that's the goal cool man
well book is great congratulation thank
you I think it holds the power and the
potential to help a lot of people and I
suppose that's a good thing in the world
man so you're blessing
I appreciate you this is how you always
on your PI I appreciate you in my life
and I do man it's been a cool journey
that we're on and it's been great to
watch you impact so many people and I
have no doubt that this will only
continue to grow and expand so I wish
you well best of luck with the book yeah
bro let's just talk again soon thanks
man appreciate it so lewis howes calm
you're simple to find on the internet
yep just out Lewis Howes everywhere
that's it and he's cranking out content
like nobody's business check out the
podcast the books cool greatness folk as
well and we'll talk again soon man
basement appreciate you peace